[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
happy friday
we made it to the end of the week
it's here
soon will be the weekend
i'm sure a lot of things will happen
over the weekend
a lot of news
a lot going on in ukraine and russia
even in our own congress
i can't even figure out who the good
guys are who the bad guys are
this is not surprising though from these
these fascists that we have in this
country
that we are trying to fight in this
country
now we have bonehead of the week today
second hour
bone end of the week you know we're here
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central youtube twitter twitch
brought to you by an association with
midas touch
we are very excited to be with the midas
mighty and the mind as touch family
every
single weekday we don't miss one haven't
missed one
even when my voice was off a couple
weeks ago we don't miss a day
always here and every friday you know we
do bonehead of the week
we do a bonehead of the week poll
every
single week on at tony michael's pod go
follow us over there on twitter at
tonymichaelspot also follow me and our
co-host gabe
at the tony michaels
and at i am gabe sanchez gabe's going to
join us for bone head of the week as he
always does
got a lot of uh
boneheads on the list you know the one
thing about the bonehead poll this week
that i noticed
look
if you're on a list of boneheads
and ted cruz only gets six percent and
you ratio him by like
over 60 65
holy [ __ ] you had a horrible week
a horrible week
if you out ratio ted cruz
ted cruz even ted cruz doesn't really
like ted cruz i mean
man's best friend almost anything you
could do
to a dog right they would still love you
and his dog hates him
again everyone hates ted cruz even ted
cruz hates ted cruz and somehow somehow
and he could be on the bone end of the
week every single week we could just
throw ted cruz on there and everyone's
like yeah he he must have done something
he is ted cruz
we heard anthony scaramucci
totally ice and destroy
destroy ted cruz yesterday in the
interview that we had with anthony you
guys should go check it out
speaking of roasting ted cruz subscribe
to the youtube channel and
go you can go to yesterday's episode and
watch the interview with the mooch
where he roasts ted cruz and donald
trump of course but he roasts ted cruz
but when you beat out ted cruz by over
65 points and i think it's over 65 i
don't know the exact numbers when you
beat ted cruz by that much you out ratio
you have had a horrible horrible [ __ ]
week but it's not hard for these
fascists it really is not because to be
honest with you
we did this poll late in the week on
thursdays we are deciding to do the
bonehead of the week poll later and
later in the week to make it more and
more relevant on friday because these
[ __ ] can't stop boneheading
they can't stop doing stupid [ __ ]
and we have today trending
a bunch of fascists in the congress
who can't seem to figure out
who a murderous dictator is and who the
murderers dictator isn't
they can't figure it out they just can't
help but placate to putin
they're put in with putin it's
ridiculous it's not surprising really
that they would love authoritarians or
totalitarianism it's not really
surprising fast that's what fascists
love they [ __ ] love it i'm gonna play
a video for you today
you've seen this video the the the the
mommy mode video holy [ __ ] this guy i
don't know who the [ __ ] this guy is
but the mommy mode thing jesus [ __ ]
christ
it's ridiculous
so we're gonna we're gonna play that
and we've got uh
we're gonna talk about hunter biden's
laptop that's all big news big news
hunter biden's laptop of course
we're going to talk about hunter biden's
like that we'll probably talk a lot
today about hunter biden and hunter
bindings i don't know why i have to keep
going over this
but i do and it's going to continue
because these [ __ ] idiots can't
figure out that we're not necessarily
all
big fans of hunter biden
we're not
so what
okay
we'll
we'll work through it
we'll work through the hunter biting
[ __ ]
i'll help us get through that that
garbage
the garbage that is the hunter biden
stuff
it's the the right wing is absolutely
obsessed
i mean [ __ ] obsessed
with hunter biden and hunter bodies
laptop have you noticed this
i mean they're [ __ ] obsessed with it
like they know nothing else besides
hunter biden's laptop i'm surprised i'm
really [ __ ] surprised they're not
blaming gas prices on hunter biden's
laptop
i i am real i actually joe biden should
feel relieved that he may be getting
some of the blame for gas prices not
hunter biden's laptop
i mean there must be some kind of
[ __ ] secret code or secret document
that's drawing up gas prices somewhere
on that [ __ ] don't you think
maybe an email speaking emails maybe
that's another thing that's drawn up gas
prices maybe hillary's emails are
drawing up gas prices this is really
[ __ ] stupid
really [ __ ] stupid
that they are obsessed with hunter biden
like
the former president united states the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
their orange deity
has not won
but
several degenerate children
several it's not like
i mean you know
tiffany
he doesn't even know
her
and baron he doesn't know his name he
knows that melania has a son he doesn't
know his name so you know maybe take
them out of the picture a bit
but the other three
total [ __ ] degenerates
[ __ ] booger sugar junior can't stop
making [ __ ] facebook videos or
wherever hell he posts that [ __ ] i think
he posted on [ __ ] facebook our
telegram or [ __ ] i don't know where
he posts this garbage
maybe on true social no one's seeing it
on true social by the way because no one
can [ __ ] log in
but don jr post
coked out videos after coke out videos
after coked out videos and then eric
trump goes on [ __ ] fox news sean
hannity and whines all the time about
how they're gonna be [ __ ] prosecuted
and the right wing's like oh that laptop
of hunter bidens by god did you hear did
you hear the news hunter biden owned a
laptop
he owned a [ __ ] laptop can you
believe that that george soros comey
liberal owned a [ __ ] laptop
as if there's something significant
about someone owning a laptop or when it
breaks to take it to a [ __ ] repair
shop
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
so we'll break down the new york times
[ __ ] today because they got more
[ __ ]
hanging in the wings the new york times
you can always count on these [ __ ]
publishing op-eds that are [ __ ]
worthless
not only to the the public discourse in
this country but the [ __ ] fascist
lies that are continuing to spread
around
new york times
ah what's funny what's really funny
about the new york times is for the
fascist that [ __ ] is fake [ __ ] news
it's garbage liberal rag until they say
something you know in favor of them then
then that [ __ ] [ __ ] has to be real it
has to be the truth if there's an op-ed
that says their opinion
in the new york times new york times is
gold then [ __ ]
lauren bobert
another [ __ ] bonehead that didn't end
up being on the bone head of the week we
need to accept like bone head of the day
maybe bone head of the hour jesus christ
to keep the [ __ ] up with these idiots
oh
let's go to the the greetings this
morning who is here debbie's here
robin's here hello kathy
midas robin says [ __ ] em fam midas
mighty
lisa hi lisa good morning good morning
carter
good morning nolan
jay is here
uh who else do we have here
everyone's here everyone's here this
morning thanks for joining us here on
the tony michaels podcast remember
remember
remember you want to like
and subscribe there's a new look at the
new graphic woo baby look at the new
light graphic
give us a thumbs up it's more like a
facebook thumbs up but whatever
whatever you know what it means thumbs
up because you know i'm good at the
whole youtube thing like subscribe do
the youtube thing you know where you
point down go down to the comments to
the comments below i don't know
i don't know i don't know the youtube
thing we also have super chat now here
on youtube
if you if you guys out there listening
on the audio version uh whether you're
on the uh the the uh boycotted
directories are not like spotify we're
on spotify we're on all all the
directories whether it's boycotted or
not
we're also on apple google wherever you
find your podcast we're probably going
to be there just search the tony
michaels podcast
and we're there but if you're if you're
if you're not if you're just listening
we do have super chat on youtube a lot
of people don't know what super chat is
what that means is you guys can come to
the show live on youtube
and we can chat back and forth you can
type out a message i can see it and i
can respond to you that's what that
happens you can also do a super chat you
can buy a super sticker do a supers chat
uh it helps the show we really
appreciate all the super chats and all
the super stickers we've gotten in the
last week
really cool stuff we appreciate all the
new all the new folks here all the new
listeners we're getting more and more
new listeners every single day
every single day just like we do the
show every single day
noon eastern 11 central
right here on youtube twitter twitch
let's get to the shitless roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
eternity trends
and let's see what this hunter biden's
laptop [ __ ] is about
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the [ __ ]
list roundup where we round up all the
tweet tweets and the journey trends of
the day you know we like to go through
the news here on the tony michael's
podcast and give you our commentary my
commentary gabe's commentary
of what we see in the news the newsy
news the trendy trends the tweety tweets
maybe one day we'll go to like the tiki
talks
or the instagrams the grammy grams i
don't know we like that we like the
trendy trends and the tweety tweets it's
just organized a little bit better for
the news right we get the trending
topics we can go through
we can find each topic that we want to
talk about for the day and today
oh today boy today is is hunter bun's
laptop trending
we got
these [ __ ] morons
they got it trending out there
they got it trending uh let's let's
let's refresh the page here let's make
this a little bigger so yells can seize
you all can see the the timeline we'll
start with the timeline here
oh here here here's the the new york
times opinion
look this is this is the thing new york
times opinion
new york times opinion
now the headline is americans are losing
hold of a fundamental right as citizens
of a free country
the right to speak their minds
and voices voice their opinions in
public without fear of being shamed or
shunned
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that white privileged ass [ __ ] so you're
you're saying you're saying that our
freedom extends to the freedom and
consequences
that's white privilege ass dribble get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
there has never been there has never
been a time in this country where you
had the freedom of consequences now
the consequences that goal post has
moved sure
as society has realized yeah it's
probably not a good thing just for joe
rogan to say stuff like i don't know the
n word
it's probably not a really good idea for
someone to lose their mind in the
[ __ ] grocery store and say racist ass
[ __ ] to people
it's probably not a good idea for a a
famous person or a quasi-famous person
to go on an interview
and talk about how they have homophobia
probably not a good idea in today's age
to have some of those views because
those views [ __ ] suck they're [ __ ]
dumb it's stupid
most people realize that that the rights
ideas [ __ ] suck they know that we
know that their ideas [ __ ] suck
that's why they're so [ __ ] butthurt
about having consequences of their
speech listen when you read your miranda
rights your rights [ __ ]
you had the right
to remain
silent
how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] did we lose this in this
country
that we don't understand that freedoms
have have two sides
when you have the freedom of speech you
do have the freedom of speech but he
also had the right to shut the [ __ ] up
you don't have to speak
you don't have to give your opinion i
mean i give my opinion ever here every
single [ __ ] day two hours a goddamn
day
i don't have to
i do
because i have that freedom in that
right and i feel like i can yell and
scream into the microphone but that
doesn't [ __ ]
preclude me from any consequence
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you bunch of goddamn snowflakes you
[ __ ] trucker convoy type
[ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here whining and
[ __ ] crying
i i i've
put up with this for years
that the left is some kind of bunch of
oh you guys want safe spaces and you
you're a bunch of snowflakes [ __ ] your
feelings all that [ __ ] there ain't
no [ __ ]
there ain't no
group of people
that melt into a puddle of ice cream
quicker than the right
i mean quit fasting in a hurry
room temperature melt into ice cream it
doesn't even take like a heat lamp
so what you're saying is
i want to be able to say whatever i want
to say but have no consequences i'm a
white man
and i should be free to say whatever i
want whenever i want especially about
people that i don't like and especially
when i say they shouldn't have speech
and they shouldn't have identities and
they shouldn't live the way they want to
live
that's what they're saying
that's what the [ __ ] that's what this
whole [ __ ] goddamn riff is about
is white men who look like me
losing just a smidge of their privilege
in this country because let's be frank
let's be frank it'll take a long
[ __ ] time to take the privilege
completely away from a white male in
this country
as much as it is instituted into our
society
and our institutions
and the system for that matter
i can't wait for the day when women
[ __ ]
have the reigns of power in this country
and can [ __ ] fix the [ __ ] that white
dudes have [ __ ] up for the last 200
goddamn years
it's about goddamn time we do that [ __ ]
but these people
want to have the freedom of speech
without with the freedom of consequence
when has that ever been an american
thing
i get to do whatever i want whenever i
want no consequences
i get to speed when i want no one can
[ __ ] stop me
i get to break any laws i want i don't
have to have a license to drive i don't
have to have insurance to drive
i could do anything i want whenever i
want because america
and i should get to say whatever i want
without anyone giving me any
consequences
it's white privilege drivel
it's what it is
it's grievance
white male grievance i know i is one
i've been around these [ __ ] i
hear what they say when it's only white
men around oh [ __ ] white dudes talk
way different way [ __ ] different
white dudes
talk way different when it's just them
when it's a crowd of white dudes you
know a gaggle like four five six maybe a
dozen white dudes sitting around a table
in a group
they talk way [ __ ] different
i know these [ __ ]
i know how snow flaky they are i know
how terrified terrified
they are
that they're gonna be out demographic
and it's gross and it doesn't just bleed
into politics it bleeds into every
[ __ ] system there is
that's why they're so [ __ ] pissed off
about the politics of it
it ruins it for them right
because they don't have the right to do
whatever the [ __ ] they want say whatever
the [ __ ] you can say whatever you want
that's why i never advocated for joe
rogan to be taken off spotify frankly i
think the [ __ ] should stay on
spotify
i think the country should make that
[ __ ] we should make that mandatory
listening to [ __ ] hear what these
dumb [ __ ] are saying you know i
advocate for not looking away here on
this show
stop looking away just because it's hard
to [ __ ]
to know that there's pieces of [ __ ] out
there you still gotta know
you gotta know what you're up against
it's the fight for our democracy you
don't think
you don't think it's the fight for our
democracy it is
they're at war with our democracy go go
talk to any rural white dude and ask him
say are we a democracy are we a republic
just ask that question
just that [ __ ] question right there
to some [ __ ] rule white dude just in
a grocery store
or wherever your church your community
someone you know you're like oh this
person's smart
they'll know that their they'll know
that a republic is a democracy they'll
know we're a democracy they'll know that
nope nope no they won't
go ask them they're like oh we're
definitely a republic we're not no
goddamn democracy
because in a republic white dude's rule
see that's how republic should work is
white dudes take over everything and
control all the power that's what they
mean that's what they mean that's the
code talk
[ __ ] they said let's go brandon for
[ __ ] [ __ ] months
they lost that didn't they
they always are in code talk mode that's
what republic means republic means white
dudes in power that's why they don't
that's why they don't like democracy
because when a white dude when white
privileged white dudes in this country
think of democracy they think oh my god
well if we have democracy god don't let
women have control of stuff
can you imagine a woman having control
of government oh that'll be awful sure
they'll regulate what we do with our
bodies
they'll regulate what what what we can
and can't do with our guns
they'll regulate what we can do in our
sex lives who we can have sex with and
who we can't
they'll do all kinds of crazy things to
us because that's what they do
that's what they do you see
the reason why white [ __ ] are
so [ __ ] worried
because that's what this is that's what
this freedom of speech without
consequence is it's all white privileged
[ __ ] all of it
don't get it [ __ ] twisted that's what
it is white grievance white privilege
[ __ ]
white white dudes are terrified
absolutely terrified that if there is
equity and equality in this country
and if people of color bipoc women
whoever lgbtq
oh my god if they're in power they'll
try to oppress us like we want to
oppress them
that's how they think because they want
to oppress these people fascist white
white male fascists want to oppress the
[ __ ] out of people that's what they want
to do
that's what they mean by freedom of
freedom of speech without consequence
a good example is that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] jeff younger down in texas who went
and spoke at unt the university of north
texas and didn't in denton
and those students protested him
if you don't know who jeff younger is we
had him on here as alpha uh as bone head
of the week or avoca of the week i don't
remember but there was a very very very
viral video that came out of the
students at unt protesting that
[ __ ] they were chanting [ __ ]
these fascists
jeff younger is reigning for congress
jeff younger has a transgender daughter
jeff younger tried to make sure that his
transgender daughter couldn't be
transgender daughter
he lost that battle with the mother
of his daughter
he's so [ __ ] butthurt he's such a
[ __ ] fascist that not only does he
want to prevent his child
from having their identity
but every other child in texas and not
only not only does he want children not
to have their own identity he wants to
make it a crime
for the parents for that child to have
an identity
don't even get me started on the don't
say gay bill
but that's their motive
and what happens is i i posted that
video
the video of them chanting [ __ ] the
fascist on tick tock i don't know it's
got like on my tick tock account that's
got over five million views
five million for that video
number one comment from fascist
white dudes in the [ __ ] comment
section
and even stitches and replies or
whatever the [ __ ] it is over on tick
tock the number one [ __ ] stupid-ass
trope
is
well
it's it's his freedom of speech to say
what he want no it's not
it's it's his freedom of speech to say
what he wants in a public space
now he was invited to unt
he was invited
and they protested him they have the
right to speak just as well as he has
the right to speak just because their
speech was louder in the room
doesn't mean he didn't have the right to
speak
but his they kept saying oh well you're
trying to kill other people's ideas and
opinions look
wanting people not to be in society
is not an ideal trying to pass
legislation
to make sure that a certain group of
people are not welcome in society that's
not an idea that's not a [ __ ] opinion
when you start legislating it's not an
opinion anymore
that's not a thing
especially when you're taking liberties
away from people whether it be lgbtq
bypoc women whoever
if you're taking [ __ ] liberties away
from people it's not your opinion
anymore
you're oppressing people the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not
liberty it says it in our [ __ ] intro
every single day
and you have the freedom to speech you
can say whatever the [ __ ] you want
i don't i actually i think everyone
wants to tear down fox news and cancel
fox news listen
if we didn't have fox news
would we know that there's a fascism
problem in this country i don't know
that we would
i think everyone would turn a blind eye
to it just let oan and newsmax and
infowars
you know continued to dilute the
population into these fascist ideas
without it being right out in the open
like oh [ __ ] that's a problem because
fox news isn't the problem folks it's
not fox news
it's the same thing they blame
social media it's and they blame the
algorithms yes of course of course the
algorithm is programmed a certain way to
get a certain outcome outcome but with
social media and algorithms it's garbage
in
garbage out
garbage in
garbage out it's the same thing with the
media
it's the same [ __ ] thing
garbage in garbage out garbage in
garbage out
but that garbage has the freedom of
speech in this country
we have some of the
the
least strenuous laws on speech in this
country
but that still doesn't [ __ ] keep you
from being held to account for your
speech dummy
if you have a really shitty take and
we're gonna get to kyle rittenhouse
which is a really shitty take if you get
if you have a really shitty take in this
country
and then you publish it
publicly for the entire world to see
you're probably gonna be roasted for it
that's probably a thing that's going to
happen like no time in our history
really
have you been able to the normal average
person be able to
post their shitty take on a topic
and then been able to be a hell held
account by the entire country
never time social media has delivered us
that ability now you used to be able
like like put in like uh you know
letters to the editor you know maybe
there's something going on in your town
that you didn't agree with you know
maybe a dildo shop opened up down the
street and everyone's oh everyone's all
upset that there's a rubber dick store
in the town now oh my god what are we
gonna do
oh oh all that lube and rubber dicks oh
my god i've seen this in in rue america
white rural america they lose their
minds
when a porno shop opens up oh my god
there's a there's a goddamn store down
there that sells him rubber dildos can
you believe it tammy
loses their minds
loses their minds and you would write an
op-ed right you've been riding an op-ed
have a really shitty take on the dildo
store but look
maybe maybe at best at best a couple
hundred people are gonna read your
really shitty take
on the dildo shop right
earl writes an op writes a letter to the
editor to the local newspaper
a thousand people get the paper couple
hundred people read his take his stupid
[ __ ] take on the dildo shop that they
just opened up on main street
and bam that's it you know that's it
but nowadays nowadays that's not the
case
that's not the case earl would go on the
facebook page right
be a national national headline or
something and earl would go on the
national headline and type out his
opinion
and the whole for the whole [ __ ]
world to see
the whole [ __ ] not just not just the
people who buy the local paper like it
was before now the whole world sees it
and earl's mad earl's mad that his
speech his bad take about the dildo shop
is gonna cause him consequences
because before before it didn't cause me
consequences before the system was set
up that i could have my shitty takes my
shitty opinions i could voice them and
no consequence no one would hold me to
account
in white america
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
okay let's go down the timeline a little
more
here we go here's more of this [ __ ] this
is the mommy mode said the fascist
that's what i said uh 50 shades away
posted this video uh women are currency
to be bartered that's what this [ __ ]
guy says here um
i i'm not sure let's see let's go to
this thread i don't know who these
people are this this this
lauren lauren winski i think is the the
lady here down at the bottom
i don't know who this who this guy is
this ted nugent style guy have you
noticed that more and more of these
people these [ __ ]
these white male nick fuentes uh america
first nazis
uh looked more and more like ted nugent
like from the 80s have you noticed that
what the [ __ ] is with that
what is this [ __ ] i don't know i don't
know but you see the american first
stuff hanging up in the background all
his nazi flags hanging up and you know
that's that's really what he's what he's
saying here is that he's a nazi
uh you know it looks like he's in his
bedroom in his mommy's house it really
does but you know that's that's neither
here nor there we'll get to that but
listen listen to what this
this nick fuentes america first nazi
has to say about women pay attention
this is very important this is [ __ ] you
can't look away from this is [ __ ]
they're saying
to each other
right
everyone's wondering why why like
florida's trying to out texas texas and
texas is trying out
florida florida missouri's passing laws
idaho's passing laws to make sure that
women don't have liberty do you do you
want to know where they're getting it
from do you want to know where they're
getting these grand ideas this dumb
[ __ ] listen to this [ __ ] my real
position is that
women are our currency to be
bartered and uh traded you know we see
in the bible it's not biblically
unfounded it's not a lot like i'm making
stuff up and and being disrespectful or
anything but it's like oh yeah it's not
like he's making [ __ ] up or being
disrespectful no problem
no problems no problem
with calling women
a human being
currency
are you did you hear what he said should
i rewind it
i'm rewinded what is this a vhs tape
[Laughter]
play it back
i guess it's still rewinding it isn't it
i don't know
w with i guess maybe maybe this guy
tricked me into thinking i was in the
80s still but the way he looks that's
why i said rewind
this this is [ __ ] boneheaded type
[ __ ] and you're wondering you're sitting
around wondering where where are these
republicans getting this stuff
where where is marjorie taylor green and
matt gatz
and the and paul gosar mo brooks louis
gomer donald trump these america first
idiots where are they getting this stuff
from
how could they this dude
this dude the tail is wagging the dog
and it's this dude that's giving him
this side this is the republican party
you may not think you're like oh my god
that's not tony come on that's a stretch
nope
not stretching it at all this dude right
here
on this whatever this show is whatever
the [ __ ] they're doing here
this is the republican party
this is it listen like you could trade a
nice virgin bride for a half a dozen
yolk of oxen and i think if we went back
to that and got rid of all this feminism
crap forget about your master's degree
forget about your career and just go
mommy mode that's what i believe in
mommy mode
all right
so the guy who has his mommy
washed the [ __ ] stains out of his undies
he probably i mean i don't know where if
these guys could find
a girl to attract or not i have no idea
i have no idea
i don't know if if this guy could find
a woman who would even attempt to find
him attractive
not physically i'm not talking about his
physical appearance i mean that's a
whole nother [ __ ]
that's a whole nother [ __ ] issue here
i'm talking about his views
can you imagine can you
can you imagine this day and age in 2020
this guy going on a date you know he
takes his date to mcdonald's or wherever
the [ __ ] he takes her i mean you know
they're fans of donald trump so they're
probably fans of mcdonald's too yeah it
takes maybe he buys her a big mac you
know i mean i mean i'm saying you know
he doesn't get her like the four-piece
chicken nugget he gets her a big mac
maybe like an iced coffee or something
you know there's something nice at
mcdonald's for crying out loud i'm
giving him a little too much credit but
i'm just saying
you know i don't want to i don't want to
say
that he's a dumb [ __ ] but he's
definitely a dumb [ __ ] but you know
maybe maybe he would treat her nice
nicely at mcdonald's but let's say
you're he's sitting across from a woman
at mcdonald's
and he starts to tell her this [ __ ] that
he thinks she's currency
and he wants her to be in mommy mode
really mommy mode
because that's what this kid this did i
call him a kid because he is a [ __ ]
kid this this kid
he's never he's never been responsible
for anything obviously if you look at
his bookshelf back there he doesn't have
one [ __ ] book on it not one [ __ ]
book not one
he can't even he can't even [ __ ] hang
his posters up straight
i can't even hang them up straight
he's got the nazi flag going
but look
this
is why
the laws that are being passed the
fascist state that is being laid out
is being laid out because they are
listening to this america first agenda
you don't believe me
marjorie taylor green
the leader of the republican party she's
the [ __ ] leader she's the one
they won't kick her out if she's not the
leader why wouldn't they kick her out
why wouldn't they
matt gatz he's a he's [ __ ] under
investigation
for trafficking minors
and he's still a congressman
are you are you listening to my voice
when i'm saying this
this this guy right here
is the republican party let's listen to
what else garbage and vile this [ __ ]
idiot has to say
yeah
do you uh do you uh
think that i think that they should also
like
you know how there used to be like
dowries back in the day like
you'd have to like yeah i think that we
should bring that back however okay so i
was talking uh with okay
so they want to bring back galleries
right
this i don't i i've never i've never
been in a culture
where there was galleries i never really
experienced this in my life
um there's a reason for it because
parents selling their daughters to men
really is [ __ ] gross and it it it is
trafficking you're selling another human
being right i mean that's what they're
talking about here
that women are currency women are to be
traded and bartered they have a monetary
value and not to themselves like
women do have have value women do
like
humanity right
like they're [ __ ] human beings
but what they want to do is dehumanize
women
so much so that they can just sell them
off
yeah they're worth you know
this many dollars that many dollars
who can who can give me the largest
gallery for my daughter
this
is the republican party everyone's
standing around wondering why is
missouri making it a felony for a woman
to leave the state
to get a medical procedure why in the
world would republicans in texas want to
make it
where they could execute a woman for
having a medical procedure
how could we ever get to that point
because this [ __ ] [ __ ] here
is wagging the dog this guy is the tail
wagging the dog
nick fuentes and his following
are the republican party
jesus christ nick fuentes on his [ __ ]
show whatever the [ __ ] it is
was is cheering for russia and putin to
win
and we have a bunch of [ __ ] fascists
who voted to make sure
i mean they voted against
giving any any kind of greetings to
russia we'll go through that in the
tweety tweets and journey trends but i'm
telling you right now everyone's
thinking oh this is a big joke you know
why why is this guy relevant
whoever he is i don't know who the [ __ ]
he is i don't know the reason why is
because the tail's wagging the dog and
this is the tail
this is the republican party i think she
was indian woman about her arranged
marriage but here's the deal with that
okay so here's the deal with arranged
marriages is that your parents want
what's best for you so if you let your
parents choose for you they're
absolutely going to choose the best not
exactly what you want maybe not like
because of course we always choose what
is the worst for us um at women as a
tendency so i like fully support
arranged marriages oh women has a
tendency choose the worst
choosing and like make like choosing the
family that you choose to bond yourself
with like i fully support that i think
that's great um i think that we should
do more of that i think we should
what they're also saying here
which is code talk is white people
have to be with white people we don't
want we don't want people to choose who
they love if they choose you they love
jesus christ they might choose a liberal
they might choose someone of the same
sex hell they might choose someone of a
different race or different religion we
can't have that
we can't have that so we must sell our
daughters
because women have value oh my god okay
one more thing before i leave this video
that i want to point out here
and you know i'm i'm not trying to be
nitpicky here right i'm not trying to be
[ __ ] nitpicky i'm just
observing things
just observing
where the [ __ ] is the headboard like you
know
i might take this guy a little just a
little more seriously not a lot don't
get me wrong not a lot but just a little
more seriously if he you know
could afford a [ __ ] headboard right
like something something maybe even
something like like some kind of like uh
pinterest thing that you put on the wall
or some [ __ ] you know you see those
[ __ ] videos where they build this big
headboard or you know handmade headboard
or something
i don't know who this guy is
but he needs he needs he needs to get
out of mommy mode
he needs to get out of mommy mode
and start washing the his own [ __ ]
stains out of his undies and maybe then
maybe then he would understand the value
of a woman and go get a [ __ ] job dude
go get a [ __ ] job so you can afford a
headboard take those [ __ ] nazi flags
off the goddamn wall
and learn the real value of women the
human value
of women
it's much more than you'll ever know
okay let's let's move on oh here's the
bone head of the week
we'll get to this later look at the
marjorie taylor green ted cruz and
candace owens
we'll get to that at top the hour we're
46 minutes into the hour
oh let's go back
um oh did you notice that rachel
bitkoffer
was
debated charlie kirk i got that she
posted this link
they called her the crt advocate
that's funny
so i've i've watched and it's it's a
it's a good it's a good debate she
stomps his ass of course
of course uh here aaron has the uh eight
russian agents voted against removing
the most favored trade status for russia
and belarus their names are biggs bishop
bobert gatz green grothman massey and
roy all the [ __ ] nazis
voted for the authoritarian to keep
normal trade
with the murderous dictator who's
committing war crimes in ukraine
they love war crimes the i mean you know
these fascists love war crimes
they [ __ ] love war crimes
they love it especially especially when
it's an authoritarian committing those
war crimes they love that kind of [ __ ]
can't help it we had aaron on last week
uh maybe i'll try to invite aaron on and
give us another uh update uh on ukraine
aaron does a lot of good uh updates over
on tick-tock i don't know if you guys
are on tick-tock or not uh he he does
tweet out two on twitter so follow aaron
aaron parnez
um here on twitter but also go to tic
tac and follow him over there he does a
lot a lot of videos over there on
ukraine keeping everyone up to speed on
ukraine
um so go go follow aaron over there
thanks aaron for all the updates that
you do have um
i want to play this video but not really
because it's hard to hear them say this
stuff but here's the trucker convoy you
can see the convoy's rolling through
like a almost like a residential area in
dc um andrew reports here the trucker
convoy is making its way through the
capital city horns blaring the residents
yelling at them go home [ __ ] off
you see this guy here down here
uh on the bike uh he's he's flipping
them off
people in dc are not are not [ __ ]
happy are not [ __ ] happy about uh a
bunch of people in pickup trucks you
know the 14 or whatever it is the 14 of
them that are in pickup trucks running
around still blaring their horns they're
[ __ ] sick of these people um which
they should be
oh here we go bad company put this on
this kid is very disturbed yes he is
this is the kyle rittenhouse thing
speaking speaking of uh consequences of
speech
is [ __ ] idiot
kyle rittenhouse and i usually don't
retweet these [ __ ] but i wanted
to make sure that everyone knew where to
go to see this son of a [ __ ] i didn't
know that kyle rittenhouse even had a
[ __ ] twitter account until a couple
weeks ago
didn't even know he had one
um of course he takes the [ __ ] video
of him in the trial where he [ __ ]
murdered people at a black lives matter
rally he drove across state lines took
an illegal weapon to go kill people you
know if you're a medic
listen if you're a [ __ ] medic
your number one goal isn't to make sure
you're armed you're armed with like
medic type [ __ ] like first aid type [ __ ]
not just [ __ ] surgical gloves and an
ar dummy
he's a [ __ ] murderer and he's a god
he's a goddamn he assaults women too i
don't know if you've seen that video he
assaults women
sucker punched the woman in the face
several times little [ __ ]
and here the little [ __ ] makes a
[ __ ] video about how he's crying
about gas prices i said killer take dumb
[ __ ]
this is another thing where they're
they're mad
about their freedom of speech um we've
had uh one more thing and 50 minutes
into the first hour we're going to be
going to bonehead here soon
but
dakota adams we had on um i noticed this
this tweet the other day it says heads
up
ammon bundys people's right network
which i've never heard of before prn
appears to be potentially be gearing up
for another armed conflict
this is from prn leader brand thorton
brand thornton is apparently uh one of
the leaders of the uh of the network for
the bundy ranch you guys you guys
remember the bundys you remember this
[ __ ] um
this is this is the the to the the
caption here the tweet on the i i don't
know i guess it's on facebook here
that's what it looks like to me that
they're on facebook um all men a militia
age active or not need prepared to save
baby cyrus from the trial child
chapbackers at ada county idaho that
sounds really weird like what a baby is
being trafficked in a county well so i
wasn't aware what this was
um i seen this tweet i'm like whoa this
is a bundy ranch thing so i actually
said we just were talking about idaho
and bundy in the bundys with dakota
adams now as you know uh we interviewed
uh dakota adams last week on the updates
of some of the plea deals and
indictments that have brought down on
not militia groups like the oath keepers
which stewart rhodes uh is his estranged
father dakota's estranged father
who is in who is in charged with
seditious conspiracy and also joshua
james who has pled guilty as an oath
keeper to seditious conspiracy but also
enrique tario a proud boy leader who was
uh indicted last week on the same
charges um but we seen a video resurface
of him and stuart rhodes
uh meeting in a parking garage january
5th in dc which enrique tario was not
supposed to be in dc
and raises a lot of questions and we
asked those questions to dakota you can
go again you might want to subscribe to
the youtube channel you definitely
definitely want to subscribe if you want
to go watch that interview a lot of
people have watched it
uh dakota i believe i believe it's uh
it's in the clips
uh uh playlist if you go to the clips
playlist and just it's the the recent
dakota adams i think it's the third time
we spoke to dakota and i hope to maybe
bring him back next week to see if
there's any updates on this bunny ranch
uh well bundys people right network
whatever the [ __ ] that is
um so i was trying to figure out what
the hell this was
and dakota um
says that uh getting ready for [ __ ] to
get stupid ammon bundy is determined to
be a martyr if he can't be a messiah
apparently what is happening
um in ada county
is someone has had their child
protective services has taken a child
away from someone from one of the bundy
people i guess i don't know in their
group or family
and they're calling it sex trafficking
that they're that they're taking the
shot this is really [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ]
because not only these right wingers
calling this sex trap when when they get
their child taken away from them it's
sex trafficking because they're abusers
but
in texas in texas they're all for the
law of parents having their child taken
away from because the child
is trying to figure out its identity
right that we're good with we're good
you see the [ __ ] pattern here
uh
so maybe we'll get dakota on next week
to talk about this uh topic if
especially if anything happens um
i i've retweeted this but here is the
link here's let me let me retweet this
again to the top of the timeline here is
the link to that interview that we had
with dakota the youtube links right
there um so go check that out let me
give dakota credit here um dakota is a
really really really bright individual
um
he not only has
a really good insight into the militia
but like he grew up around it have you
seen our interviews with dakota and go
watch them uh we had one with him and
his mom tasha which is an extended
interview i actually talked about how
stewart rose lost his eye on that one
but they do give more insight into
stuart rhodes and even like the
evolution of the oath keepers because
the oath keepers were not what we think
of them today when stewart rhodes
started it when he founded it it's not
the same thing it's evolved over time
but they talk a lot about that there's
an also i think another interview um
where we talk about stuart rhodes uh
detention uh around that time so
okay
here's then
um
oh here's the hunter biden's laptop
thing okay let's talk hunter biden for a
second before we go to bone hen of the
week
because hunter biden is trending um i i
tweeted this out a while back and i
think we and we had it on the show
um yesterday
i said imagine how filthy a laptop must
feel when hunter biden turns it on
it's just a joke it's just a joke
and the reason why it's a joke because
i'm poking fun at these people for being
obsessed with hunter biden's laptop
it's just a joke
but the joke is on them
because i also say what happened was i
went and i posted this on instagram
and i was like i need to write something
different than this so i wrote
not everything is hunter biden laptop's
fault sometimes it's hillary's emails
i thought it was funny so i posted the
joke
but here's what's not a joke folks about
this hunter biden let's go to the trendy
trends let's go to the hunter biden
trend because i want to talk about
hunter biden for just one [ __ ] second
let's do a hunter biden rant
uh the new york times article details
the department of justice inquiry into
hunter biden's business dealings
including emails between him and his
associates obtained by the publication
from a cachet of files that appear
to have come from a laptop abandoned by
mr biden in a delaware
repair shop
sounds real sinister right
also today or yesterday the headline was
hunter biden has paid off
he paid
a significant tax liability
okay
he paid a significant tax liability
but a broad investigation into his
business dealings that started with a
tax inquiry has remained active this
this stuff happens this stuff happens a
grand jury is still seeking information
about payments from around the world
all right so let's start with hunter
biden first
and then let's talk about okay so hunter
biden
let me let me make sure i have this
right
the president united states has a son
right
and the assumption is is that when the
president united states became the
president
that he would divest in his personal
businesses that he had with his sons and
his other
children right and that the idea and
then
and then his children but he didn't
divest the present united states did not
divest in those businesses he didn't do
what he was supposed to do
right
his degenerate children his crackhead
children
ran the [ __ ] company
all the while all the while the
president united states
had his children and his in-laws
as official members of the government
not just official members of the
government though
official members of the administration
inside the white house
this is scandalous type stuff
i'm telling you
this has very rarely happened in the
history of our country
and we need to be looking into this
because the present united states is
responsible for this
not only did the president united states
make sure that his children had
had reigns of control over the
corporation that he did not divest in
but made sure to install them
into the government
making choices even even so much so
even so much so that the spouses of one
of the president united states children
would go over and make deals in the
middle east
which seem like peace deals but also
seems suspiciously like financial deals
that would benefit you know the
president's children and their spouse
even the president's children
would go to china to speak to diplomats
on the behalf of the american
people and that child of the president
united states would receive almost
immediately trademarks in china
that were that stand
to gain millions tens of millions of
dollars for the president united states
child
would you believe me if i told you the
president the united states private
company that business
business dealings that he had with him
and his children became
under investigation not just civilly but
criminally in a state
not only that not only that the
president of the united states and his
child
his children
they would be criminally indicted the
business that they own the business that
they ran would become criminally
indicted
the company that the president united
states and his children ran for decades
becomes criminally indicted in the state
of new york
and also under civil indictment
investigation excuse me
by the attorney general
for possible
fraud charges
civil fraud charges
by defrauding the state
by changing the value of their real
estate
can you imagine can you imagine our
current president of the united states
and his child doing this how much of a
scandal it would possibly be
i would imagine i would imagine that
most people in this country republican
democrat conservative liberal no matter
who it was would be disgusted and
grossed out by that those facts that
would lay bear in front of them
and i would imagine i would imagine that
if
another president had a kid that was
kind of a degenerate
and the president knew that that child
was kind of a degenerate made a lot of
bad decisions in life doesn't really
have their [ __ ] together probably
shouldn't put that person in government
not only that that if they were under
investigation by the department of
justice or the irs or whoever was a
grand jury whoever was making sure that
that that that child of that president
who has made some bad decisions in their
life was held accountable if they needed
to be that he would stand out of the way
and make sure to let that happen
these are two different stories folks
the first story is not hunter biden
they're projecting when they run around
yelling and screaming by hunter biden's
laptop
it's all a distraction
it's all a distraction from donald trump
and his family's businesses
everything they say about hunter biden
everything they project on hunter biden
that's exactly what the republicans are
supporting
exactly
the trump organization the company that
the former president united states and
his children ran the same children that
were part of the government of the
united states that went overseas and
represented us us citizens our country
as representatives of the united states
officially in official capacity
is under criminal
indictment
don jr
charges people
2 000
to have a signed picture
to line up
to take a picture and have it signed
how many [ __ ] would line up to
get a picture a signed picture with
hunter biden i wouldn't
i don't know one [ __ ] that would
get in line to take a picture a signed
copy picture with hunter biden
and that is the story of the two parties
in our country right now
that's the story
that's the story line that's what we
that's what we're dealing with
that's what we're dealing with
jesus christ they run around talking
about how there's a big cabal and and
the queueing on [ __ ]
trafficking children all kinds of crazy
ass [ __ ]
and they have their one of their one of
their leaders of their party
matt gatz one of the leaders of their
party they love this guy
i mean god he's on the phone with the
president every day
i mean same as madison cawthorne
matt katz is under investigation
for trafficking a minor
madison catherine there's another good
example
is in court trying to fight for his
right to even be a congressman because
of sedition because he tried to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states
now whether that'll be successful or not
i don't know
but no one's lining up to hear hunter
biden speak no one's lining up to take
pictures with the [ __ ]
joe biden joe biden didn't have to
divest a personal business with him joe
biden didn't [ __ ] make make him part
of the administration joe biden knew
that hunter bite he loves him he loves
him he's his son
which makes joe biden a very empathetic
very caring loving decent father
because he loves his son
and that's probably the problem that a
lot of people have with this
is that that he hasn't cast hunter biden
out
maybe if joe biden cast hunter biden
away or maybe if they made him and made
him part of the maybe maybe if joe biden
said hunter here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna go over to the middle east
and you're going to create peace in the
middle east that's what you're going to
do that's going to be the thing you're
going to do maybe they would be like oh
well that's great we'll line up to take
pictures with him and
i'll sure i'll hand over my monthly
salary to take pictures and sign a photo
with hunter biden sure
that's what they're doing on the right
don't get confused clown these
[ __ ]
if hunter biden's indicted fine whatever
joe biden's not gonna stop it
i don't believe maybe he will maybe he
won't we'll figure that out
but he hasn't he ha i mean if this if
the story in front of us for the new
york times is correct joe biden is not
stopping a grand jury
into seeking information about payments
that job are excuse me hunter biden's
made around the world
and also
also
hunter biden paid off a significant tax
liability
so like you know
he did a thing that he shouldn't have
done now he's he's paying it off
like you should
if you're worried about being
upset
about
one of the president's children
you're focusing on the wrong [ __ ]
president
and you're focusing on the wrong
children
all right dad we have gabe with us gabe
howard how are you gabe
there you are
i don't know i don't know if your mic's
working or not
i can't hear you can't hear you let's go
to a break we'll be right back as as as
our co-host gets his uh
tries to get his mic run now can't hear
you can't hear you might have to go out
and come back in we'll be right back
we'll be right back after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i think we got our uh technical
difficulties the mic situation
worked out over there with gabe i think
i think he finally i think he finally
figured it out he he's getting to where
he knows how these these mics work did
you get your mic working over there
i think so okay i think we can hear you
we can hear you
all right cool yeah yeah yeah we can
hear you
okay so so we got bonehead of the week
this week
um there was a lot of boneheads and and
it's piled on even this morning
these yeah these boneheads i mean just
just in the last 24 hours we've got like
well i like a dozen more bone hens that
we could add to this bowl it's kind of
ridiculous it's it's pretty crazy and
but not but not surprising i will say
this people whenever whenever we put out
the poll they're always like
i need an all option i need an olaf
right if that was the case so that's all
that would win ever right and i want i
wanted those other like what when the
idea originally came and i was like hey
i think this would be fun to do
uh
it that all is a cop-out no offense i
get it that all people are are boneheads
on the list but
you gotta pick the one the winner right
you can't have all because then it's
always going to be all right right what
because they all are boneheads i mean
right exactly i mean we we got we got at
least two dozen boneheads that we could
pick out right today oh yeah and
everyone would select like if we put
them all on a pole you're like yeah all
of the above
you're like if you're basically asking
like all right are these all bone heads
yes no you're all going to say yes right
we're all going to be all right so it's
like you got to you you i get it you
want it all
but sorry not sorry you gotta pick one
well here's here's our boneheads of the
week this week it said uh marjorie
taylor green
and ted cruz and candace owens
uh everyone's seen this poll so i'm just
going to show it it is absolutely crazy
to me
that marjorie tate look how look at the
ratio how she yeah if dude have you
ratio ted cruz like this
you have had a horrible horrible week as
a bonehead don't you think yeah well it
was you know it was just like one thing
on top of the other it was like third uh
wednesday was
the applause non-applause situation
right right right which we'll talk about
right right and then of course you know
she doubled down on it stupidity and was
like wow the cdc and the polio vaccine
when they have the fourth vaccine and
it's like yeah actually polio does have
four vaccines right right well yeah
she doesn't even know that she actually
has four polio shots like she's right
right but who knows maybe she doesn't
have no she does she absolutely
she absolutely does that's not see
that's that's the craziest part is all
these people um advocating as anti-backs
and the vaccine's bad and you know it's
mandates bad like you have all your
vaccines because of mandates like you
have them and you're fine you're walking
around you're doing you're you're
creating crazy chaos just fine just fine
it's it's it's insanity yeah and then
and then we had where she she talked
about how
she doesn't like being called a nazi
oh did you see this did you i didn't i
didn't i don't know if i saw that but
that's
we'll try to show this we'll try to show
that again i'm sorry not sorry right
well you know these boneheads and
i updated her photo i see that i see
that you updated well
is this this is this the the the mean
video or she's really she's yeah this is
why i post workout and she goes joe
biden is a piece of [ __ ]
that's that's the that's the the picture
from him yeah and it's like yeah uh
i had to scrub through that video the
like five or six seconds it was to find
the right
the right one yeah
so why is ted cruz on our on our
bonehead elite list uh you kind of you
kind of chose these yesterday yeah yeah
ted cruz is on the list because of his
trucker convoy [ __ ] right oh oh oh you
mean like uh his his cosplay stuff yeah
exactly trying to do the the cotton out
of the truck and does this whole like
i'm going around the beltway and and
it's just like you know that's the main
one there might have been another thing
that happened this week but uh yeah i'm
in the let's see i'm in the ted cruz
thread here um and i um uh he he's he's
proud to endorse herschel walker
walker was obviously another candidate
too but he only had like a day or so
right right yeah right i mean literally
here here's the thing we used to do
bonehead sir early in the week by the
time we got later in the week we're like
oh my god i don't we don't we couldn't
even remember right even doing it later
on like wednesday or thursday we still
can't even [ __ ] remember why we yeah
every day feels like a decade you know
like and that's their purpose don't you
think it's just waterfall the
bone-headed [ __ ] right yeah i mean it's
like you know i i don't know if it's a
cor if it's uh
if it's coordinated or uncoordinated
where someone goes oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] up
okay someone else do something [ __ ] up
right and they're like either on par a
little bit less or a little bit of like
more of a bonehead and you're like great
as long as it's all news coverage on you
i'm good to just like hang back and
people forget because honestly it does
happen like within the week you're just
like
this is uh within hours
something can totally change
and then the next day you're like
i thought that was last week this person
you know so it's like
very uh
very fast-paced it's a [ __ ] well
i mean and trump the trump
administration kind of did this to us
right like it never really
american politics like in the news as
far as that goes was never like this uh
so much until trump ran and won right
because it's just like is create as much
chaos as you possibly can just have this
waterfall of [ __ ] on on
on the country and they won't be able to
[ __ ] remember what you said on monday
like right
and the left is horrible at this like we
really are that's why we try to every
single day just
we try to pound the microphone because
if we say some crazy [ __ ] today you know
maybe next week on tuesday they'll
forget because we've said so much i mean
that's kind of the point and it works
for them it works
um but ted cruz here is endorsing
herschel walker which i think this is
probably
out of all the things if you watch we
want is that yesterday we watched that
uh yeah that was a political ad against
me continued like holy [ __ ] that was a
really good two minutes i can't imagine
another two minutes of that right
but
there's a thing too like people are you
know whenever i make a video about
christian people always like
harp on the whole like
uh his dad domestic abuse assault kind
of thing and i'm like i'm
i'm not gonna even touch that
right because
that is a hot mess
and i'm focusing on this other person
right now yes they are related obviously
one
doesn't influence the other
right but uh
whenever people like oh yeah hershey
walkers i'm like that is true
but i'm not gonna dig at someone i'm not
gonna dig at him for his father [ __ ]
right right like i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna go against the sins of you know of
his father to go against his own
ridiculous character i mean unless they
were the same sins right i mean if they
were operating in this whatever it was
together sure yeah fine but but they're
not but it wasn't and right you know
what i find really hilarious about this
this tweet from ted cruz here
is it said i'm proud to endorse herschel
walker for usn in georgia and the reason
why he's saying this probably is because
herschel walker is ted cruz's neighbor
in texas
he didn't even [ __ ] live in georgia
right yeah
he has a
he has a uh a white house or something
yeah he has an address in georgia it's
the same type of [ __ ] of like dr oz has
an address in pennsylvania but he lives
in new jersey is this the same [ __ ]
where like mark meadows his wife rented
the the [ __ ] trailer home or whatever
to make sure he could vote is that kind
of the [ __ ] because marjorie taylor
green actually she actually bought a
property
uh or something or her family did or
some [ __ ] that way she could run in the
district she's in right she does she's
not from that district right same thing
with josh hawley like oh gosh holly
don't even get me started he's from
missouri but he's right
he's never he hadn't lived here since he
left to go to college right so you look
at all it's you know typical there's
always like it's voter fraud and it's
like well it's actually coming from your
party right all right these guys are
running uh legitimately in this state
it's like they don't even really live
here
right they our residency is in a
different state and they've registered
to vote i mean even his wife
registered in two different states in
georgia and in texas came to 2020. yeah
did she vote in both or just one
because i mean you could be registered
in two states you know accidentally like
let's say you let's say you uh move from
one state to another and you forget to
to
change your registration at the state
you came from right like when people are
moving i understand you're packing
you're moving you got a lot of [ __ ]
maybe your kids are changing schools you
know there's a lot of [ __ ] that happens
when you move i can understand that you
forget to change your registration where
you came from you just change it where
you go i understand that so
so
what i see here is that so the case
against julie blanchard his current wife
and did after an investigation by the
secretary of state's office found
insufficient evidence which secretary
said georgia georgia okay insufficient
evidence uh to prove that she was
ineligible to cast an absentee ballot in
georgia from her and walker's home in
texas so she living in texas cast an
absentee ballot she got you what you
mean one of them one of them real evil
uh
uh uh cabal mail-in ballots like one of
those
yeah yeah the one that you've seen
hershel walkers herschel walker's wife
did a did a crazy cabal
crazy mailing ballot oh come on okay ted
cruz your [ __ ] tweet sucks
it's it really sucks
okay um so that's that's uh uh well yes
i'm gonna tweet that yes i wanna tweet
it god damn it you think they'd caught
on to that by now okay so napa ted cruz
let's go let's go to the next uh
bonehead which ted cruz the reason why i
started with him is because he only had
like you know two percent which is
really surprising it surprises me now
because candace owens even out ratioed
him by a significant amount
um yeah like 3x you're right right right
so what what did candice do that we need
to know about this week
candace works for the the russian
government pretty much uh her tweets are
getting retweeted and used as propaganda
i mean you see that with madison
cawthorne and other people uh
uh tucker carlson
but candace owens over here is victim
blaming
ukraine
and putting her you know putting all her
chips in with russia essentially
so
uh
i think she's doubled down on it there
and i'm sure oh there's also there's
also thing about covid loss of life and
covid there is yeah the thing about
russia and ukraine
so she just has a lot of shitty takes
this week yeah yeah i mean she normally
has a lot of shitty takes but this week
she really like she's parked on all of
it is this is this one of the no that's
that's this is one of those
because she's like an invisible war
about covet and these are all these are
all the flags of people who have passed
because of covet right so so what she's
saying is it's fake
and then uh
that that you know you know she's she's
uh turning points usa
talking head right if anyone doesn't
know uh candace owens with er is with
turning points usa which is a charlie
kirk organization
um which you know we've talked about the
last few days because uh a regular guest
on our show rachel bickoffer actually
debated charlie kirk did you know that
that's up on youtube that's up on
youtube you can go watch it i i saw that
i have not watched it yet but i do know
it's on youtube well and there may may
or may not
there may or may not be clips coming uh
from the show so stay tight if you don't
want to go watch the whole youtube video
over there on turning points youtube
channel uh there might be some clips
coming from that show um is this one of
the tweets that she had this week yeah
that this is
one of them
again this is the same type of stuff
that you see coming out of the mouths of
madison cawthorne who are saying that
like zolensky's a thug he's a globalist
and he's you know
uh he's oh well yeah the right wing in
this country is the kremlin's content
machine at this point right exactly
i mean they don't even have to create
content for russian state television
anymore
they just they just like take tucker
carlson and uh turning points usa
talking points they take uh speeches
from congress people and
i mean they don't even have to create
content anymore right at this point just
copy paste
that's all they do and they slap on uh
on a
a russian translation and there you go
right maybe maybe we should find a
government that wants to uh you know uh
oh yeah yeah well i mean yeah i mean why
not maybe there's a government out there
that will like
democratic kind of government or do you
want one that's like on the rising of
overtaking the government well we we are
we aren't uh pro-democracy here but you
know um we haven't received our soros
checks yet so
you know kind of antsy right well so
maybe maybe we should make the turn to
uh find an authoritarian government that
would take over a sovereign a sovereign
nation and commit war crimes against
their their citizens
and then support them maybe uh really
grossly it'd be really vile and gross of
us to do that like candace says here she
says president zlinski is a very bad
character who is working with the
globalist oh my god this [ __ ] against
the interest of his own people
i will not move one inch away from that
assessment
ever
no matter
how flowery the media depicts different
pictures
and you know what when she does you know
what she's going to end up back on the
bone end of the week yep because she is
go she is going to move she is going to
move here tony's going to be but the
fact that she could she could watch
what's happening in russia and be like
putin is killing innocent lives he's
he's he's bombing hospitals maternity
wards
uh
areas of refuge
and then
candace owen go over here goes you know
who's the real bad guy it's a lenski
he's he's not the guy who's bombing
ukraine it's zielinski
it's the guy getting bombed it's the guy
getting bombed that's the guy who's the
bad guy yeah
it's com and the reason why is because
he's acting in the interest of the rest
of the nations around the world right
like she means when she here's what
she's saying here both because she's
she's she's yelling into a megaphone for
white people okay that's what she's
doing she's saying working with
globalists globalist means people who
are pro-democracy she's talking about
you
she's talking about you people who are
pro-democracy that want the voice of the
people to be heard no matter what
country it is and yes again we say it
all the time on here democracy is not
perfect it's not supposed to be perfect
to be frank and it's not supposed to be
easy it's supposed to be hard you're
supposed to fight for it but that's what
she means she means
pro-democracy people who believe in
humanity that's what she means by
globalist
that that's what the [ __ ] she means this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] it's his bonehead
um let's see what reid has to say here
um
reed reed of the lincoln project says a
real candace oh
now please don't move one inch quote off
this belief keep saying say it
everywhere say it to those moderate
republicans who stand with ukraine and
think you're a nut candace owens is the
republican party
she
is the republican party
whether you like it or whether they like
it or not mitt romney
this is your leader
you're not the leader of the republican
party mitt romney you ran for president
mitt romney yeah and you're not the
leader and i have no good things to say
about mitt romney nor liz cheney or adam
kinzinger everyone wants to praise them
oh they're so great they're so good but
listen when i tell you this mitt romney
adam kinziger liz cheney will be back on
this bandwagon as soon as it's
convenient for them right as soon as
it's convenient for them
candace owens is the tail that is
wagging the dog did you see the video we
we played it earlier of the the guy with
laura uh what's her name when winsky or
whatever her name is
it's some kind of some kind of ted
nugent looking [ __ ] he looks
like
an american nurse
yeah yeah yeah i saw yeah yeah yeah nick
plant is nazi where he was talking about
how women should be currently he looks
like a young dog the bounty hunter yeah
yeah yeah well i i i say ted nugent
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it makes me think of ted nugent right
um but that is the republican party at
this point that's who they are candace
owens that dude their republican party
is like you know you look at the
republican party and they may be like no
we're not nazis it's like but here's the
thing the loudest people from your
whatever sect of your group of the
republican party are the ones saying the
stuff they're the ones who are getting
attention they're the ones there you
know uh
patriot front
uh are are
uh out marching you've got america first
and nick fuentes having these
white nationalist
conferences you've got martyr taylor
green going there and speaking and then
saying oh i i don't know who the guy is
i've never seen a video never met him
before just went there and uh went to go
get some young bodies you know some
young nazis
and then you've got other people who are
you know trying to
do other like extreme
things against people's rights and uh
you know liberties
and they're like that's not us and it's
like well if that's not you
then you better make sure as hell that
you'd establish and be loud about it and
drown out these other people i'm not
obviously like i would much rather deal
with the liz cheney's
of the world
than i would
the
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
madison cawthorne josh hawley tom
cottons of the world right
because i feel like at least with
someone like that
there's some
element of compromise there's a little
bit of of an expectation where we could
meet in the middle on some things right
but if you've got this group who are
yelling profanities and vile things and
saying you know basically
proving that they're fascists and nazis
then there's no hope right and if you
want to beat out that
uh
that noise
the republican party this core group of
like we're the grand old party right not
the
grand old putin or the gqp or whatever
uh they need to they need to figure out
what their their messaging is they need
to figure out what their narrative is
because
right now
these crazy extremists are co-opting the
republican name well what's that what's
the old phrase about eating dinner with
nazis right have you heard this you
don't you shouldn't right right all
right right but if you you may not be a
nazi but if you're having dinner with
them
you're with the nazis you're right
you're what is it it was like uh if 10
people had it is like 10 people at a
table or nazis and you're the 11th right
you're a nazi you're a nazi you're a
[ __ ] nazi well i have i have a i have
a
a tick tock that i did a long time ago
because people kept getting really mad
at me for calling the white people nazis
they're like you shouldn't call all
white people nazis i'm like
i i'm not calling all white people nazis
and the video goes something like this
if you're mad that i call white people
nazis in my videos
i'm talking to you right like yeah like
you are who i'm talking to that's who
what my content is made to target you
yeah and get in your ears if you're
upset that i'm calling white people
nazis because most most white people
who understand like oh well there are
nazis and there are not nazis but when
he's calling white people nazis they
know who i'm talking about right right
now the people who are offended the
people who responded like i'm not a nazi
it's like
yeah
you're the 11th person
you're willing to tolerate because
that's uncomfortable for me to call what
to call people nazis right right which
we'll get to here in a bit with the
bonehead of the week but that we got a
dishonorable mention here
um i'm not even sure who this is peter
schiff
uh he's always like hawking gold and
[ __ ] oh yeah uh but what is it is he got
like a radio show or some [ __ ] i don't
know he has a podcast
oh but he's most [ __ ] with
those podcasts he's the guy that came
after zielinski because he didn't wear a
suit when he was addressing i get that i
got that tweet pulled up here right um
he says uh let me pull the banner down
here he says i understand times are hard
but doesn't the president of ukraine own
a suit um he's referring i think to the
uh
to the address that he gave to the
united states because he's wearing like
a green t-shirt right which he has worn
every single day
because he's getting [ __ ] attacked
and ukraine is defending themselves and
he stayed there he hasn't he hasn't run
to his bunker he hasn't run to another
country yeah you know it's the true like
i'm going down with the ship kind of
mentality so right right which which i
mean i hope we don't have a situation
right
um president zielinski's life is uh not
i mean he is in danger but his life is
taken from him i actually think that
would be a a very very very bad
strategic mistake not just for putin but
their russian army if they were to do
that but so i i hope he doesn't but he
is he is he's like
it's it's called
war pete it's called war now he says i
don't have much respect for current
members of the united states congress
either
but i still wouldn't address them
wearing a t-shirt i wouldn't want to
disrespect the institution or the
wouldn't
united
to disrespect the institution of the
united states i wonder how peter feels
about the insurrection i can only guess
i can only guess how he would
how he would love not to disrespect
institutions or the united states like
the constitution or the congress the
[ __ ] out of here who is this guy [ __ ]
this guy [ __ ] this guy i'm telling you
man he's just he hawks gold and he
it's it's just well good for him i mean
at least he has a sponsor we don't even
have a go maybe we should get a gold
sponsor yeah maybe would you hot gold if
we could not gold sure yeah i would i
would sell gold i mean would you guys
buy gold if we hot gold here yeah i'd
say in the comments
get me gold you know
uh
joe says i don't know who the hell peter
ship is but i do know that he is a piece
of [ __ ]
apologies to [ __ ]
oh joe she's always after my heart with
her tweeting she's so quick on that i
know i know i know oh my god that's
hilarious apologies to [ __ ] from joe
okay we have we have uh we have another
uh
special person because i want to save
enough time for the actual bonehead
right there's a lot of [ __ ] that went on
um but this next this next one's gonna
take a bit of time too i believe um
we've got uh alpha cuck of the wii alpha
cuck
we need a sound for that again yeah and
you know um the alpha cuck of the week
is uh of course representative madison
cawthorne um i'm not gonna call him this
because i feel bad call you know to call
him this but some people there are some
people out there that call him sitler i
don't i don't want to call him that um
because i think it's kind of you know
it's a little outlandish so i won't call
him that but some people do call him
hitler have you heard that that they
have heard that yeah okay i i have not
called here's the thing i'm not going to
go after him
i'm not you know not going to go after
that because that's ableist you know i'm
not going to go after someone's
disability
either yeah sure right but
the guy's a piece of [ __ ] all right
outside of that he's a nazi yeah he's a
nazi and
uh
there's a tactic that madison uses where
he will use a pun and the only pun he
uses is to use the term stand
right so he's like i stand
oh he says it all the time right right
he does it and then obviously it's a
he's goading people
to come at him
where they say oh you couldn't stand or
you couldn't do that if you tried or
whatever obviously going against a
disability which is like an easy target
but it's a low-hanging fruit and what
ends up happening i've seen it before
people go after him for the whole sit
stand thing
and then he then attacks them and says
oh
i'm the victim you're attacking me
for uh my disability right right why i
would love to have madison on you know i
would i would have madison on the show
here and eat his lunch and i would ask
actually ask him how he feels
about people i'd let him i'd let him
have his moment
to how people feel that he they call him
uh sittler i i won't call him that but
you know there are people who call it
that um here is
gabe gets cringy when i go to the hitler
thing um ron had this uh this video is
posted by raf sanchez um
republican state tv reportedly showing
this clip of madison catherine calling
zielinski a thug is that why he's on
bone end of the week is that one of the
reasons that is one of the reasons yes
okay uh the best propagandists for putin
in the world are uh us republican
politicians i have to tend to agree with
uh ron on that one um here is the the
video here let's play this and then
we'll talk other reasons why this idiot
might be bonehead or excuse me alpha
cuck he's alpha cuck of the week
wait wait a second wait a second does
madison con there speak russian
yes he does
uh
no yes this is not this is not this is
no this is kremlin tv baby oh so you're
saying what you're saying is in this
video
the kremlin this is the kremlin content
creation
yeah yeah crew there's ripping through
it gabe craig
creation
and k i mean i'm just telling you might
want to write that down um and you might
want to remember that but
if anyone's listening if you're just
listening out there this is a video
we're not playing a russian
uh video well we are playing a russian
yeah
right from the rnc they're not just
playing this like the moments right now
that he's speaking about ukraine this
has been long ago were he speaking this
is when he first misquoted uh who is it
george washington or jefferson
but that's when he was what was the
misquote again
i don't know well let's listen you can
listening if you're listening to the
audio uh podcast version you're like why
why is madison catherine in russian and
it's because they're playing him on
russian tv and they're they're
translating
him what he's saying into russian
because they want the citizens to
believe what this fascist is saying
actually
all those listening they're even showing
his tweets
they're showing his tweets do they
translate his tweets even into russian i
don't know that's okay you know um you
know i didn't notice because i follow uh
president zielinski
on his twitter account and what he does
when he posts he'll post um a post
in in english and then he'll post it in
which is smart
right right so so he'll post it both
ways so that so that's like it's like
translated for you you don't have to go
translate or it's not it because i think
the other thing too that he's been
careful about is he's like here's
english here's ukrainian i'm not going
to post in ukrainian because
someone
is going to
mischaracterize or misquote what i said
right this is how it translates and it's
right are we our mistranslate right
maliciously or you know innocently right
right right right he's just trying to
say this is what i'm saying in ukrainian
and this is what i'm saying in in
english exactly
uh let's let's finish the yeah
so not only are they showing us tweets
on russian tv they're translating it
because you know it's it's good content
yeah it's good kremlin content
is like you know not all russians speak
english so who knows what that
translation really says right exactly
well i mean you know you would want to
make sure even though the english
version is very pro-putin you would want
to make you would want to make sure
you would want to make sure that so
oh so so the the thing that happened
with madison cawthorne was when he gave
the speech
at the rnc
uh he said
you know
uh this is in 16
no this is 20 20. oh 20 20. yeah he goes
if you don't think young people can
change the world then you just don't
know american history and then he was
talking about you know going on note
accomplishments of george washington
abraham lincoln and his personal
favorite james madison while in his
early 20s and then he said
thomas jefferson was 33 when he wrote
the declaration of independence
and people like
uh
and then or and then he went out to
comment about how james madison signed
the declaration
of independence and people are like
he never signed that document like
you said he's your favorite but then you
said he signed this document this really
important document that established our
independence
and that's not the first time madison
cawthorne has done that on multiple
occasions said the same thing
no no
misquoted different historical moments
because he also said in other he's like
i'm a bit of a
history nerd you know
and he's gone
into uh
oh you know that the words madison
cawthorne and history nerd in the same
sentence right come on man yeah so i
look at that and i'm like uh you dumbass
but anytime he goes on the floor and he
tries to quote something from a
historical event or figure
he will nine times out of ten get it
wrong he'll say the wrong word or he'll
misquote the person wrong or incorrectly
and then he gets owned by it and then
people just keep bringing up the fact
that he said he's like i'm a history
nerd you know i know my history sure you
are well you know the more important
thing here is and then aaron posted this
an hour ago it looks like it is uh kevin
mccarthy um man he's getting really like
ashy and he like he looks like his his
hair is getting real it's it's really
bad i mean i'm gonna i'll tell you this
it's really bad the
aging
and stress that the republican party
puts on you like if you walk in you're
like yeah i've got no i i don't care
about people and all this like maybe
you'll be fine and you know you continue
to live that life but maybe you come in
with uh pure intentions and you you know
get converted into this life by
uh by submission or by being you know uh
an accomplice in something or complicit
in something but not saying something
right and it slowly eats your core
and as a result you look like [ __ ]
over time you age and you you just fall
apart so you're like how did this person
go from this to this in a short amount
of time
it's because the evils of the republican
party that's what i think i think it's
it's the evil rotten core
that infests everyone else
and sucks the life out
because you have to make
certain compromises
and uh sacrifices to stick in this
political party
and and continue to be relevant well you
know i think you make a good point
because it would be really hard to sleep
at night when you know that candace
owens and and the the uh the ted nugent
guy
and uh people like madison cawthorne and
matt gatz and marjorie taylor green are
really the leaders of your party and
they're saying they're like they're
going to nazi rallies right they're
going to nazi rallies
and it must be really difficult for
people like kevin mccarthy really to
sleep at night and i'm sure that really
doesn't help the process of aging
or not aging i guess you would say so
let's listen to what this dumb [ __ ] has
to say it's only 55 seconds here and i'm
sure he says some stupid ass [ __ ] let's
listen
one of your colleagues uh madison
carthorn called
i love how i love how this reporter
calls madison catherine one of his
colleagues yeah it's one of his
colleagues this is the this is the
[ __ ] minority leader in the house
he is the leader of the caucus that
madison gothard is in why is this
journalist calling madison cawthorne one
of his colleagues
why yes they're both congressmen but
this is the [ __ ] leader of the
minority which madison gawthorne is well
i mean like i guess it'd be like why
would he call him that you know and then
you could look in and say well
is it that they're colleagues it's you
know what would he what would he say
he's subordinate but if he calls him
colleagues then he's putting them on
equal footing that's right and he's
saying and he's saying like oh this guy
said some pretty dumb [ __ ] yeah but but
are you good in leadership but the point
of leadership though is to take
responsibility for what you're he won't
do that he won't do that well right we
know that i mean i mean he's the guy
that refused to sit down and he did his
filibuster moment
whatever how many
weeks months ago that was
uh
this [ __ ] guy let's listen let's
listen to the question let's give him
his fair do here for the 55 seconds
have you spoken to him and you support
his re-election
um
madison is wrong
if there's any thug in this world
[Laughter]
yeah we watched yesterday in a theater
that's identified in the front and the
back from the
housing children
yeah
it's horrible [ __ ] this is wrong
this is the aggressor
this is the one
that needs to end this war
this is the one that everybody should
unite against do you support his real
life
yes
of course i do oh and all the other what
is it eight or ten or twelve of them
however many in his caucus that voted
that voted
yeah eight of them what it might as well
be all of them at this [ __ ] point
right if he can't if he can't reign in
eight [ __ ] to vote to make sure
that we're not having
current trade relations with russia and
belarus who are [ __ ] reigning bombs
as he said reigning bombs down on
maternity hospitals committing war
crimes
he can't even get eight of his [ __ ]
members to make sure they vote in in the
way of democracy but he
supports their re-elections right i mean
the fact that he can sit there and be
like and it wasn't even like you know
there there didn't seem to be any
empathy there didn't seem to be some
compassion he literally was like
just listing the things that are wrong
he's like the putin is the bad guy right
the only thug is putin okay great
but
are you condoning what he said
like what is your what is your you said
putin is the o like you said he's wrong
but that's it that's all you said you
said he is wrong and putin is the thug
why are we not getting more from uh
kevin mccarthy because we never will get
more that's probably the most will get
right absolutely for the same reason
that he was nearly silent when it came
to ma uh marjorie taylor green during
her whole
whoever right
he's done it multiple times for all his
members matt why is matt gatt still
still on the judiciary committee why
why he's being investigated by federal
agencies why is he still even have any
committee uh uh uh assignments in the
first place when bob menendez the
democratic senator from new jersey was
being under investigation was in federal
court he did not have any committee
assignments right and you shouldn't
there should be no conflict of interest
and kevin mccarthy's also the guy that
got all but hurt when it was like oh no
uh jim jordan can't be on the january 6
committee right this is unfair this is
unreasonable and it's like oh you wonder
why it's because well jim jordan just a
complete piece of [ __ ] right but also
uh
he was involved in january
he was involved in january 6. it's like
we've got they've got the literal
receipts the logs of calls they know who
he was calling when he was calling his
involvement because up until that point
jim jordan was just like uh i i spoke to
i mean i talked to i talked to p i talk
to people i talk about i have a phone i
own a phone i have a phone yeah like i
made some calls i don't know i call my
mother or i call my sister
you know but i mean like i talked to
trump i don't know when i exactly i
talked to trump but i've spoken to trump
in like
on the january 6 are we talking like
before to 2016 right right like that's
the when you've got someone who can't
just be like
i call and tell them good morning every
morning and then we talk in the
afternoon we talk in the evening several
times too but that day i can't remember
if i talked that day specifically you
know there was a lot of significant
stuff going on it would be hard to
remember um here is here is the moment
that kevin mccarthy and the reason why
madison gawthorne uh is the alpha cuck
of the week let's let's listen really
quick to what to what uh maddie has to
say about president zielinski
so they can defend themselves
that's all you need to know zalinski is
a thug that's all you need to know about
madison gothard now let's go gd boom
yeah uh
has a statement like that who's the tree
that madison cawthron beat up
[Laughter]
and it said madison cawthorne is a thug
yeah
i think someone tweeted that actually
yeah i don't know right
yeah
so our bone end of the week uh marjorie
taylor green
uh um old marge
um why is
why isn't she yeah i mean at this point
you're just like why
you know what yeah why isn't she on the
list mm-hmm uh because she is the list
you know right she is her and bobert her
beau bert and um who else who else has
really been some
tucker carlson those three really i mean
we need to go back and really check to
see like records yeah like who's been on
the map
booth can you review the footage cool
great like
i'm just gonna have my non-existent
intern over here yeah yeah yeah yeah we
well i i can go back i'll go back and
look at the winner all i'm saying is
that when i'm because i'm doing this
bonehead madness but i wanted to wait
until the first round or two because
there's just so many teams
um
i guarantee one of those three will be
in the final four oh absolutely how
couldn't they yeah
so everyone out there listening um
gabe is has something exciting for
bonehead it's called the bonehead
madness for march um not to be confused
with march madness we definitely
couldn't say march madness yeah we can't
stop marketing it right we can't cbs is
going to come after me
right we cannot say that that it has
anything because it doesn't have
anything to do with merchandise yeah it
has nothing to do with march madness
right it's just like during that same
march madness because during that same
period of time right yeah it's in the
same march madness bracket you know of
time right but if we keep saying march
madness someone from cbs is going to
come that represents march madness and
you're saying there might be a
controversy that we're saying i'm saying
none of them weren't going to be a march
madness controversy it's it's bonehead
madness right right but they're gonna
say like oh well similar no no we're
saying we can't we can't use that
because of copyright we can't use that
right yeah you can't use march madness
we're not going to cover we're not even
going to say that about march madness
we're not even going to say that that's
not we're not going to say march madness
anymore no absolutely not we won't yes
it happens during march and it is
madness okay so it's bonehead madness
yeah not to be confused but okay
i just want to make sure
not march madness
i want to make sure that we're all on
the same page here yeah even with cbs i
want to make sure that they're not
confused okay so so why then is marjorie
taylor green what was the trigger
exactly
with marjorie taylor green being
bonehead of the week uh so this week it
was her
response
to president zielinski there could have
been something earlier in the week but
that was the one that really kind of
started it off mm-hmm uh where she
you know her lackluster her trepid clap
as daniel dale will say
uh what do you call it what do you call
it did he say it was like a trepid clap
i don't know i don't i mean i think
that's the big word that daniel dale
used he said trump and clap
so not yeah not to be confused with duck
clap just drop it a trumpet
i mean she may have i mean i'm not going
to say rather she does you know right
right that there are several different
definitions she's definitely had affairs
and i don't know if they've been safe or
not right right yeah
but that was one and then immediately
after the address that zelinski did she
had a pre-recorded response
that went out as if people had requested
a response from her
no literally no one was like hey marge
you should do it it was just march being
like i feel like i should do this so
you're saying she pre-recorded this
before she even heard what he had to say
that what you're saying i know it sounds
crazy
well let's let's let's play a bit of
this uh this this here
if we truly care about suffering and
death on our television screens we
cannot fund more of it by sending money
and weaponry jesus christ
to fight a war they cannot possibly win
it's not our responsibility to give
president zielinski and the ukrainian
people false hope about a war they
cannot win
we can do all this without sending a
dime and without shipping bonds to
further inflame a war whose outcome
already seems certain
if we truly care about suffering and
death on our television screens we
cannot so um obviously the the clip here
this is from patriot takes uh ben my
zealous repost this uh says this
despicable response
by marjorie taylor green to zelinski's
address to congress today she states
money and weaponry should be sent should
not be sent to ukraine and says putin
will win
she wants you to know she rubbed her
palms during a speech that was a clap
i don't know if everyone's aware out
there but
there was a little bit of a
back and forth between midas touch who
is who is our uh we're in association
with midas touch to be to be completely
transparent right um i don't think
that's a
thing that we try to hide here but it's
conspiracy yeah yeah well it is we are
part of the uh you know the uh my
zealous brothers cabal as the stoolies
would say
um the bar stoolies and dave portnoy um
but here's the thing is is that uh
marjorie taylor green when zielinski was
uh being introduced
she did not clap that is the thing that
did not happen right um let me see if i
can find
hell boy oh boy oh boy
um here here is a uh
the tick tock version of it it looks
like um that's that's a still let's
let's go let's find out
beer hall project has it here
[Music]
this is the this is the clip that midas
touch
uh had had posted and when they posted
they said in the tweet it says
when zielinski was introduced and
announced
marjorie taylor green did not give
applause watch with your eyes
see if you can spot her they do a real
good job of when you're out
um there is no clapping when this is
when he was being announced right and
there was no clapping from her
that's the thing that happened
so that that he she did not clap when
she was announced so they didn't lie
right yeah um then daniel dale of course
your favorite uh your favorite guy in
the world yeah you and daniel kind of
had this relationship going on
where um he he fact checks how many
times has he fact checked you he's he's
done it once with a big x he drew a big
x on my my my tweet what what was the
tweet about do you remember the tweet
was how trump uh
was calling uh
mike pence week
so mike pence had given a speech at the
federal society
and admitted that the 2020 election was
not rigged or whatever they're like no
no big lie
and uh trump
uh i made a release within 20 minutes of
that happening and basically said uh
pence is is weak and he couldn't say to
my face
and uh yeah i remember this election was
stolen
and then it
uh it went it caught like wildfire i
remember this moment because this is the
moment when
when specifically
um
you out trump trump because that's
really kind of what happened is you
released a statement that was so
trumpian that they had to release and
release another statement that didn't
even sound like trump like it was
obviously written by enough daniel dale
seemed really pissed off about that
because it kind of he kept that at he
like pinned that tweet for
at least two days right oh did he
wait he pinned the x tweet yeah yeah oh
wow you were in top of his feet for two
days no i i i kept checking i was like
man i don't know
not letting this down i didn't know that
but what daniel dale did is instead of
fact checking the actual uh marjorie
taylor green speech that is riddled with
[ __ ] lies and she's propagating uh
for putin here then
propagating for a murderous dictators
committing war crimes uh let's play
another clip real quick um but
instead of fact checking that he
he went through he had to spend eight
hours and i i actually think that i
i want to say i i caused this and i'm
that's the story we're going with here
on the johnny michaels podcast i don't
give a [ __ ] what anyone says we i caused
this because i i actually tweeted
underneath to have you page daniel dale
for a second opinion because newsweek
actually fact checked the the midas
touch clapping marjorie taylor clapping
first and then daniel spent eight hours
really coming through the video seeing
exactly how many times time codes
yeah you know daniel dale really did his
due diligence in making sure he knew how
many times her her hands touched each
other because that's top-notch
journalism that's right that's what's
important right that's what's important
not not fact checking this [ __ ] gross
vile ass video let's watch another clip
of this and the more we involve
ourselves in this foreign mess the more
we force our enemies and frenemies
together playing right into china's
hands
every move the biden administration has
made has hurt americans and helped putin
our former allies are looking at us and
wondering if we've gone mad please don't
send please don't send weapons to the
ukraine so they can't fight russians and
kill russians um and stop helping that
who didn't understand but that idea that
it's like everyone else is looking at us
like what the [ __ ] going on no uh
again we've got neutral countries that
were neutral during world war ii that
are now like yeah this is [ __ ] up
russia should not be doing this stop who
is who is who is
outside of uh
those who support russia like what
countries or leaders are being like the
usa
they're in the wrong they're the ones
who are who are the bad guys here like
who who's actually saying that
the only ones that are that may be
depend i mean there's american
corporations that are still doing it
like the koch organization right right
and several others and several others
but let's well that's that's they're not
on they're not saying that the u.s is
wrong
or that they're in the wrong or they're
they've gone mad
they're they just want to stay there to
make money well what yeah what which i
think is a separate thing right exactly
right well let's give let's give the
bonehead of the week uh marjorie marge
marjorie taylor green hoof foot green as
i call her let's give her her dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah so she won big time
came out front continued out front never
stopped she just
even candace owens out ratio ted cruz
and then marjorie taylor green totally
stopped uh candace owens even which is a
big surprise um i was really surprised
by this poll you folks really came
through
and
made sure she was the big winner yeah
the big winner and also we went to
chicken dinner that's right we want to
give shout outs to our alpha alpha cook
of the week madison cawthorne and then
the dishonorable mention who knows who
peter schiff is he had his uh his two
seconds of fame here on this show at
least maybe he'll make the list again i
don't know i've got him saved so who
knows
what at least at least we got at least
we got is my collection of heads yeah
how many
how many bonehead heads you got remember
you remember that joe bashing movie
eight heads in the duffel bag that's
right i've got definitely more than
eight heads i'll tell you right now that
i have um
[Music]
see oh my gosh is it it's a lot of them
it's a lot yeah because not only not
only do we have boneheads we got alpha
cucks and 56 50 50 56 heads wow
56 heads that's that's how many times
we've either had
uh those are heads that have been racing
or heads that have been mentioned as
dishonorable mention or alphacock wow
wow well there's a whole there's a whole
list of them and we appreciate them on
bone net of the week thanks for joining
us money of the week uh stick around
we'll we'll do some announcements right
after this
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i almost said that wasn't it
yeah boom we're getting that transitions
right uh we have some uh big big
announcements uh we we just interviewed
anthony scaramucci go check that out um
it looks like we're probably gonna
play that on midas touch channel uh
sometime this weekend so you'll be able
to watch just the interview with anthony
if you want to watch that um be paying
attention we'll spread those uh links
around like herpes all over twitter and
all over the internet so be paying
attention what what no no
oh you like maybe the clap yeah i was
like
more appropriate considering
we were just talking about the body okay
so we'll spread it around the internet
like the clap so be paying attention to
that uh on all the twitter pages follow
us uh please please follow us at the
tonymichaels our tonymichaelspod and
then follow me at the tonymichaels and
follow gabe at i am gabe sanchez that
way you can vote next week for the
bonehead of the week poll
you can vote next week remember to like
you like the new graphic i got there for
like
like the video it's kind of like a
facebook like yeah that's you know
facebook you know on facebook yeah yeah
maybe we'll be on facebook eventually
but just just like the video whatever
you're supposed to do yeah just engage
interact right you know comment share it
comment speak speaking of it
remember we have the super chat now on
youtube so join us if you guys are
listening out there on twitter or twitch
um you can always join us on the youtube
live chat
uh we we will pull you in we'll try to
talk to you a bit if we if we can and
make sure you you can do super
uh chats or super stickers
if you guys get a chance to support the
podcast that's much appreciated
otherwise you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
i do want to uh also give a shout out to
rachel bitkoffer um she wore the fascism
sucks shirt on the charlie kirk debate
this is a gabe design by the way
everyone gabe designed this fascism
sucks you can go to the 20 minutes i see
it on the uh on yeah right yeah on the
beat night with charlie curt
um you can go to hats.d tonymichaels.com
use the promo code podcast
use the promo code podcast for 10 off
your entire order go check out the
fashion fascism sucks shirts and check
out that
that debate and if you don't want to
watch the you know i get if you don't
want to go to a charlie kirk's channel
watch the debate just stay tuned
stay tuned there will be there will be
some clippity clips coming that you'll
love that maybe we'll get charlie
trending that's kind of what he wants
anyway so but until next week until next
week on monday remember every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central right
here on youtube twitter and twitch
until monday have a great weekend and
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking